con nosotros a Marcos brune fue el
periodista especializado en béisbol del
medio Big Rider Marcos bienvenido
Gracias por estar con nosotros en
Francia 24
Gracias
comodín se han disputado con nuevos
formato Marcos de acuerdo con las reglas
aprobadas durante la discusión de
contrato colectivo que destacarías de lo
que fue esta fase
bueno primero que no fue para nada
reñido solamente el juego de los padres
y los mets se extendió al máximo de tres
encuentros y finalmente con Victoria
para los padres de San Diego una
frustración total y una decepción total
lo que pasó con los meses en Nueva York
después de todo el dinero que
invirtieron para esta temporada Y lograr
llegar a la serie mundial por primera
vez o tratar de ganar la serie mundial
por primera vez desde 1986 pero no lo
lograron y quedan por fuera y ahora va a
comenzar una serie divisional que tiene
como curiosidad que va a enfrentar a
tres de las de los de las cuatro
seriesdicionales van a ser entre rivales
de división Los Marineros de Ciudad les
van a ir contra los astros de Houston
los Philips contra Los Bravos de Atlanta
y los padres de San Diego Irán contra
los Dodgers de Los Ángeles que creo va a
ser la serie más interesante por ser dos
rivales grandes dos rivales con una la
nómina y sin duda Va a ser una batalla
extraordinaria a ver qué va a pasar
entre los padres de San Diego y los
Dodgers de Los Ángeles que ganaron la
división muy fácilmente pero no hay que
desestimar la labor que han hecho los
padres de San Diego no para armar el
equipo que tienen Sí precisamente en esa
línea ayuda a la siguiente pregunta qué
esperar de esta serie es divisionales
aparte de este hecho de que se
encuentran rivales de división Igualados
o nivelados en las series sí creo que la
serie que va a llamar la atención es la
última de los padres de San Diego y los
Dodgers de Los ángeles son dos equipos
extraordinarios con tremendas
alineaciones sin duda dos fuertes
candidatos para ir a la serie mundial y
sin duda creo que ahí va a estar la
atención no hay que descartar lo que han
hecho los Marineros de Seattle y que sin
duda aunque los astros de Houston Tienen
cinco series de campeonatos de manera
consecutiva han ido tres veces a la
serie mundial en los últimos cinco años
no hay que descartar a los Marineros de
Ciudad real que además demostraron el
día de ayer que están para grandes cosas
voltear un juego que estaba ocho a uno
en el sexto inning sin duda tienen
material material para tratar de avanzar
a la siguiente instancia la serie de
campeonato y darle una sorpresa a los
astros de Houston creo que Los Bravos
Atlanta también tiene un tremendo equipo
una gran alineación que ahorita sí
cuentan con Ronald Acuña que bueno ha
estado lidiando con lesiones que para el
año pasado no pudieron contar con él
para llegar a la serie mundial Y pues
también sin duda repetir el campeonato
de la liga nacional y y también hay un
equipo que hay que tener en cuenta creo
que la serie entre los fines y Los
Bravos favorece a Los Bravos además los
files han tenido problemas hasta el
punto que llegaron a despedir a George
girardi como manager y sin duda Los
Bravos de Atlanta parten como favoritos
en esa en esa serie tradicional y bueno
Los guardianes han tenido una un remate
final en esta instancia de septiembre y
octubre
han tenido muy muy buen mes terminaron
sacando una tremenda ventaja a los
medias blancas de Chicago para ganarse
para ganarse comodín y para ganarse la
división la división central de la liga
americana y sin duda también es un
equipo hay que tener en cuenta Marcos es
imposible a pesar de que todavía falta
un casi un mes para el anuncio del más
valioso tanto de la liga nacional como
del americana es imposible no adelantar
ya terminada la temporada regular no no
adelantar su posición es o
especulaciones sobre todo pensando en la
americana Shoes yotani Aaron George Cómo
se inclinará esa decisión para definir
al más valioso del americana
creo que la pareciera quedaron George
sale como favorito sin duda los dos
tuvieron una temporada histórica a mí
Omar me cuesta mucho definir Cuál de los
dos pudiera quedar como más valioso sin
embargo por lo que uno ve en las redes
sociales que No necesariamente tiene que
reflejar la realidad pareciera que Aaron
George parte como favorito para ganar el
mvp sin embargo lo que hizo a otani fue
excepcional es una campaña sin
precedentes fue el único lanzador y que
tiene 200 ponches y además 30 30
jonrones en una temporada de grandes
ligas
Marcos te agradecemos mucho